foreign
[Music]
we did
we're gonna talk about a scene that
takes place in the church
um oh
magnificent job you better thank you
Pinocchio pedo are having a dialogue
Pinocchio dogs about his relationship
with the statue of Jesus and it's a
quiet moment
it's a sort of moment that we were
really interested in emphasizing in
Pinocchio where you just can take the
time with a couple of characters and
really get to know them and understand
their relationship and not be involved
in lots of histronics and motion and
just focus on the emotion
papa there's something I don't
understand why this is Pinocchio
but he likes him
huh they were all singing to him
he's made of wood too why do they like
him and not me the scene is a quiet
scene that shows Pinocchio and Geppetto
getting closer and you're better being
unable to explain to Pinocchio something
important like why do they love him and
not Pinocchio
people are sometimes afraid of things
they don't know but they'll get to know
you and like you and and for that
are you ready for school
then I have something I'd like to give
you
tada
I love it Papa
I love it I love it I love it
you have Geppetto giving him a book and
still hanging on to the memory of
cardinal
it's just a school book
and Pinocchio doesn't understand what
the book is but he loves it he loves it
because it's a gift from his father and
breaks through an invisible barrier and
hugs Geppetto and love starts healing
both of them we'll see a very good boy
Papa
I've done very much
I did
I
I do
then I'll be just like Carla
and all of this turns the scene into a
beautiful Father and Son scene which is
also a reference to Jesus and his story
which is also our father and son's story
witchcraft
Pinocchio oh no please it's it's a
purpose the Father and Son story is
really the main theme of the film those
relationships and how they evolve who
controls you wooden boy of course I
control him who controls you
it's the nature of Love within a family
finding it maybe it's more about sort of
recognizing it
[Music]
[Music]
stop-motion animation is probably the
oldest style of Animation there is it
was one of the first things that artists
tried with a camera just moving a
character literally one frame at a time
and shooting it and that's still what we
do now we really have the finest
animators in the world working on this
oh yes yes yes our time Papa what is it
we use the language of wardrobe design
we miniaturize the Fabrics we age them
we treat them tint them just like that
you would do in any live action film
oh hi it's me
and the construction of the set is
layered so that the base of the church
is romantic and much older than the
upper parts of the church or the wood
carving that can take place in the 1800s
the bottom frescos and the top frescos
and the glass work take place at
different times in the construction of
the church you know we create the same
crafts or address the same crafts than
you would do in live action one animator
did almost all of this particular scene
and that really allows that artist to
dive deep into what the characters are
feeling and really understand the nature
of the performance
now be the very very best uh whatever
they do there
I'll make you proud
and 24 frames a second a good week for
an animator is two or three seconds on a
two-hour movie we had to labor for a
thousand days and more than 60 units
shooting at the same time we manipulate
the puppets very very gently depending
on their motion manipulate the face
these have mechanical faces in them so
there's a intricate sort of watch work
like mechanism inside the face that's
controlled by little Allen wrenches that
you can put in either through the ear or
through the back of the head
and then there are paddles all through
the face so that you can get very very
delicate motions out of the face and get
to really interesting expressions
the eyes being obviously the most
important part of any character
it's particular scene we light it like
any cinematographer would but you're
shooting also any moving light as if the
day is setting
Frank passing on or a cinematographer he
created gobos to synchronize with the
light so that the daylight in exteriors
and Interiors you have the sense of it
moving frame by frame as if the clouds
or the sun was moving on the sky I think
this is a very subtle detail but one
that does give the atmosphere the
feeling of live action because these
sets are static you don't get any
natural movement of light at all so
Frank has recreated that idea which
brings life to these sets even if you
don't see it you you definitely feel it
when you're watching the shot foreign
minimal gestures
fail gestures a character landing on the
bench a few inches further than he needs
to be switched over tried to close the
lid gestures are normally are left out
of those sitcoming rhythms of Animation
when people consider it a genre for kids
which is not animation is a medium to
express film and express art so all
those minimal gestures make the audience
lean in to watch the characters act
emote and feel why are you so blind so
absolutely blind he has much to learn
but he loves you for who you are just
because of the laborious nature of the
process obviously we don't shoot any
coverage so we really have to know what
we're doing when we go into a shot we've
choreographed all this one frame at a
time it's a beautiful process very very
much like live action in so many ways
[Music]
be exactly who you are
I love you
[Music]